[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique en bourgogne en
direct sur notre antenne de france
rameau gagner sur notre page facebook
nous sommes aujourd'hui à sept semaines
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en plein coeur d'une
campagne inédite à bien des égards et
nous en débattons ce matin avec quatre
invités
nisrine zaïbi bonjour bonjour vous êtes
conseiller régional socialiste et vous
soutenir benoît hamon lions marot
bonjour l'agencé régionale du fn
conseiller municipal à
montceau-les-mines et vous soutenez
marine le pen va son chemin
bonjour vous êtes adjoint au maire
d'autun président du modem de
saône-et-loire et vous soutenez emmanuel
macron enfin charles henri gallois de
l'upm bonjour vous êtes donc de l'union
populaire républicaine et vous soutenez
à ce titre son président qui est
françois asselineau alors du fait d'un
calcul de l'équité des temps de parole
sur plusieurs semaines le représentant
de françois fillon à n'est pas présent
sur ce plateau aujourd'hui mais ce sont
encore ces démêlés qui ont fait la une
cette semaine annonce de sa prochaine
mise en examen maintient pour l'instant
de sa candidature lâchage de nombreux
soutiens mise en cause de la justice des
journalistes interview de son épouse ce
matin dans le jdd
manifestation de soutien très contesté
cet après midi contre manifestation
également cet après-midi bref est ce que
tout ça n'offre pas un pitoyable
spectacle et ce qu'ont les citoyens
peuvent encore vous considérez vous les
politiques avec tout ça c'est pas qu'ils
veulent en parler me suis effectivement
c'est une si c'est une situation inédite
et insoutenable qui monopolisent
énormément de débat public
par contre ce que je déplore c'est que
nous par exemple nous sommes des
représentants de nos candidats
respectifs et nous n'avons même pas le
temps justement d'aborder des questions
de fond parler programme contre
programme de dire que aux 50% justement
de français qui ne savent pas pour qui
voter aujourd'hui
ba qui a des solutions pour la nuit
il ya aussi un programme fort qui est
soutenu par mon candidat effectivement
notamment mais ce débat là est tellement
oui comme vous dites réduit l'image de
la france à des affaires qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être
moi je me réjouis pas en tant qu'élu de
la république finalement de cette
affaire là elle s'allie l'ensemble des
élus d'un république honnête honnête
soit il est enfin un travail
effectivement peut-être un travail mais
on a une fonction qui est digne on
représente l'intérêt général et on est
finalement mis dans le même paquet le
même lot que c'est que ces candidats qui
ont des affaires sur le dos il remet à
d'autres d'ailleurs
on ignore si marino tête ailleurs et du
coup ça me c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup des affaires notamment de
marine le pen qui refusent de se rendre
est-ce que tout cela ne dévalorise pas
votre travail le travail de tous les
élus déjà si vous voulez qu'on fasse
toute la campagne sur les affaires faut
l'ouvrir déjà pour tout le monde avec la
ferme de françois fillon
on n'arrive plus à faire campagne sur le
fond c'est un véritable problème on
parle plus du chômage
on parle plus des petites retraites on
parle plus de la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat on ne parle plus du terrorisme
islamiste
on ne parle plus de la crise migratoire
et on ne parle plus de la crise agricole
fillon c'est le pur produit du mps
durant toute la campagne de la primaire
de la droite et du centre et nous a il
nous a clairement dit il a dit aux
électeurs que s'il n'était pas élu même
pas élu il ne respecte déjà pas sa
parole
car il ne devait pas se présenter s'il
était mise en examen donc c'est la
démonstration que c'est un pur produit
guen ps et donc avec cette affaire
serait peut-être temps quand même à
moins de 50 jours d'élection
présidentielle qu'on puisse parler des
programmes alors on voit les seuils pour
elle voit sur ces images notamment de
faire campagne à françois fillon
la censure est vous qui vous le modem
jour dit au centre est ce que vous
arrivez encore à vous faire entendre
dans tout ça je pense que justement on a
réussi à se faire entendre par cet acte
historique de françois bayrou de
renoncer à sa candidature personnelle
c'était le candidat naturel du centre il
aurait fait un score autour de 10 %
peut-être comme il l'a fait en 2012 et
de dire voilà on va permettre à
quelqu'un qui n'est pas du centre mais
qui a porté le projet qu'on a deux
puis quasiment 15 ans et qu'on a failli
faire gagner en 2007 quand françois
bayrou était très près d'être au second
tour et donc de permettre d'avoir
justement une majorité nouvelle de en
finir avec ce duo paul cette
bipolarisation qui abîme la démocratie
française et et une partie des dérives
actuelles notamment une partie des
affaires et de l'idée de tous pourris
aussi découle de cet état de fait que
deux parties se partageaient intervalles
réguliers des des responsabilités et
donc oui on arrive à se faire entendre
par des actes comme lac de françois
bayrou et par des parts des propositions
qui sont celles qu'on va porter en débat
j'espère qu'on reviendra dans le fond
mais une remarque sur à la fois le front
national et la sphère fillon sait que
pour être candidat à la présidence de la
république on est candidat à une
fonction qui est celle de garant des
institutions et un candidat à cette
fonction doit avoir au moins deux
principes qu'il doit défendre
l'indépendance de la justice et la
liberté de la presse
à partir de ce moment où des candidats
marine le pen et françois fillon
remettre en cause l'indépendance de la
justice et la liberté de la presse il se
disqualifie de même pour la course à la
magistrature suprême
alors parler peut-être françois
asselineau alors ce que l'on appelle les
petits candidats cette fois ci on les
voit plus du tout alors il regard vous
portez vous les jeunes il ya plusieurs
choses dans ce que vous dites
tout d'abord ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que je pense que c'est
affaire intéresse les milliards ne parle
que de ça effectivement il n'ya plus
vraiment de campagne mais je pense que
les français sont assez grands pour
juger eux mêmes et les français au
contraire aimerait aller sur des débats
de fond
effectivement on ne peut plus faire
campagne on n'en parle pas et fait j'ai
avec moi vous savez les derniers
chiffres du csa on ne peut pas faire
campagne
mais il ya quand même une promotion qui
relève de l'indécence pour monsieur
macron ça ce sont les chiffres du cese
alors ils sont pas tout à fait cela
quand on regarde sur un mois d'ailleurs
trois qui fait son travail mais on reste
quand même un des frais +2 37% du temps
de parole sur la semaine du vent cécile
soyez semaine il a présenté son
programme
bon sens et pour françois si nous parler
des petits candidats il s'agit de 0 07 %
du temps d'antenne
donc effectivement il ya une grave un
grave problème démocratique à ce niveau
là et on n'a pas clairement de campagne
pour le moment et j'aimerais qu'on
puisse aller au fond des choses et c'est
ce que propose françois sino sur lequel
on va revenir
concernant les affaires c'est un
problème de moralisation de la vie
publique et nous depuis 2011
on propose des mesures très fortes ce
sujet là on propose d'interdire tout
candidat qui a été condamné à se
présenter à des élections on propose de
ne pas faire plus de deux mandats par
candidat parce que pour nous la
politique ça ne devrait pas être des
professionnels de la politique et je
pense fondamentalement on va revenir sur
le programme qu'il ya un grand lien
entre corruption et l'absence de pouvoir
puisque le les politiques français dans
le cadre de l'union européenne n'ont
plus de pouvoir sans y avait plus de
pouvoir vous fait carrière et ça amène
des attitudes un petit peu corruptible
alors est ce sens je révisais à une
vision tout à l'heure sur sur le fait
que marine le pen et françois fillon
notamment beaucoup critiqué la justice
ces derniers temps j'ai une question
d'une internaute mylène qui nous dit est
ce qu'elle se sont au dessus des lois
est ce que c'est cela qu'elle appelle la
justice pour tous l'égalité ce qu'il n'y
a pas un monde à deux vitesses un siècle
que ça peut paraître curieux pour
quelqu'un qui veut devenir chef de
l'état de critiquer les institutions
alors déjà je me permettrai de répondre
à monsieur chauvet ce qui était ce qui
ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'on
s'interroge pas du tout sûr sur le
patrimoine des manuels macron alors
comme voix sur internet qu'il y a quand
même de nombreuses interrogations parce
qu'on compte s'interroge pas là dessus
donc j'aimerais également d'ailleurs que
les médias se déploie son patrimoine en
ligne
j'aimerais également que les médias
puissent s'y intéresser pour répondre
donc ensuite à manon je dirai tout
simplement que la décision qui a été
prise par parlement par le parlement
européen et son son président socialiste
monsieur schulz c'est une décision qui
est purement politique
alors arrive d'une des affaires mais
faut quand même il faut quand même
rappeler que monsieur schulz avait
clairement et a clairement dit au
parlement européen qu'il mettrait tout
en oeuvre pour lutter contre les
présidents un eurosceptique détendu asie
dans l'époque travaillait donc se pose
des questions c'est une décision qui est
purement purement politique et marine le
pen a d'ailleurs répondu à de nombreuses
mises en examen du parti pour
escroquerie en bande organisée et
détournement de fonds publics c'est
aussi une décision politique
allez voir madame lepage qui avait
incriminé monsieur bayrou pendant de
nombreuses reprises monsieur choix alejo
m'avancer va falloir l'aider à faire un
nom dans cette émission
le conseil constitutionnel a validé
cette semaine notamment dire un
parrainage pour alain juppé c'est celui
de la mère de votre ville de montceau
les mines
donc il pourrait être la solution de
secours bref à propos de ses parrainages
donc ils sont publiés petit à petit
depuis cette semaine sur le site
internet du conseil constitutionnel
alors on n'a pas vraiment de doute sur
le fait que vos candidats respectifs
atteigne les 5 sens peut-être pour vous
françois qui nous donnons nous nous
sommes très confiants aucun pour les 500
parrainages et ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que ces publications ne
sont pas si transparente que ça dans la
mesure où c'est pas un arrêté un moment
t pour tous les candidats
il s'agit seulement des parrainages
validé et non pas les parrainages reçu
et on sait qu'on a appelé le conseil
constitutionnel parce qu'on s'attendait
à avoir plus de 200 260 d'un ménage au
dernier relevé mais ils nous ont
expliqué qu'ils n'avaient pas eu le
temps de les traiter donc ça il faut
bien comprendre que ce n'est pas une
image un augmentée qui reflète la
réalité à la fin drainage voilà c'est
nous on est confiant et vous inquiétez
pas vous verrez français acelino cette
élection très bien pour les autres et
pas deux mais pas de soucis vous n'avez
pas encore donné votre parrainage tous
les deux d'ailleurs si c'est ça y est
mais il n'a pas été validé les parties
vont ni du parti aussi il est parti
aussi bon
parlons maintenant des sondages en
n'excluant pas l'hypothèse juppé pour
l'instant ce sont monsieur macron et
madame le pen qui font la course en tête
en tête ce pardon alors ce serait inédit
ça veut dire que au deuxième tour les
deux partis traditionnels souhaitais
plus est ce que banny screens libye
c'est pas une profonde défiance quand
même ça de la part des citoyens
la question des sondages et est aussi à
prendre avec précaution on a mis photo à
l'instant t on l'a vu déjà avec le break
site
on l'a vu aussi avec donald trump on l'a
vu aussi avec les primaires de la gauche
où mon favori notre radar n'était pas le
favori apparemment dans les sondages
mais qu'il l'a remporté donc à un moment
donné moi je prendrais des précautions
sur la question justement des analyses
des sondages qui sont parues aujourd'hui
d'autant plus qu' il ya un sondage au
doxa qui dit que si c'est juppé qui
remplace fillon il serait en tête
effectivement de la présidentielle en
france pourquoi la fin des partis
traditionnels et d'ailleurs moi je mets
dans le lot partis traditionnels le fn
il n'est pas nouveau c'est pas un parti
qui existe depuis peu c'est un parti qui
existe depuis fort longtemps qu'il n'a
jamais gouverné
oui mais qui a gouverné quand même des
communes et des collectivités qu'ils ont
aussi des élus donc on peut aussi parler
bilan un moment donné et de position
justement politique de la part de leurs
représentants politiques
donc moi la question des sondages
effectivement je la prendrai avec
beaucoup de distance d'autant plus que
ceux qui sont testés aujourd'hui ne sont
peut-être pas les candidats de demain
très bien là mais en même temps on a
quand même l'impression que la campagne
de benoît hamon pour l'instant et ne
décolle pas assez elle ne décolle pas
nous c'est moi je rejoins aussi ce que
vient de dire ses homologues ici est le
représentant masculin
il ya aussi une question de
médiatisation comme je le disais en
préambule on passe notre temps à
commenter l'actualité sur des affaires
entre marine le pen et filles ans mais
finalement parle pas de fonds moi ça me
désole parce qu'il ya un vrai projet
pour la france
un vrai projet pour ceux qui sont en
souffrance qui ont des attentes qui sont
qui n'arrive pas à finir leur moi et
qu'ils sont mais vraiment dans une
attente profonde et qui passent leurs
longs leur temps à regarder l'actualité
politique à travers les médias en disant
regardez ils sont tous pourris et ça
c'est désolant parce qu'il ya vraiment
des choses très intéressantes dans le
cadre du programme de
un nom que moi je porte aujourd'hui que
je porterai jusqu'au bout qu'ils sont à
valoriser et j'aimerais qu'on aborde
justement ce sujet de fond alors
monsieur chevet on voit qu'elle est
dynamique
emmanuel macron sa semaine notamment
aussi dans les sondages et par le nombre
de personnes qui sont donc dans ses
meetings
apavou l'attribuez-vous dynamique parce
que c'est le renouvellement
parce que c'est aussi sortir des
clivages et une dynamique a été
entretenue aussi par l'arrivée de
françois bayrou on voit depuis une
semaine que les sondages s'améliorent
encore mais sans commenter haut et il
faudrait pas et je pense que ça désole
aussi les électeurs étaient spectateurs
de considérer la présidentielle comme
une course de chevaux en sera la casaque
verte est arrivé devant la casaque bleue
et on reprend un demi point et c'est ce
que ce que ça montre l'idée générale
c'est la fin du bipartisme la fin de la
bipolarisation et sur le fond ça montre
que les clivages n'était pas ce qu'ils
étaient entre la droite et la gauche
mais que la droite et la gauche le grand
parti de droite et le grand parti de
gauche sont traversées en lors sa part
des fractures profonde idéologique sur
l'europe sur la libéralisation de la
société sur l'ouverture aussi au niveau
des moeurs sur un certain nombre de
sujets comme ça qui en fait et les
sondages le montrent on peut rassembler
des gens de centre gauche et de centre
droit autour d'un projet cohérent alors
que le ps lui-même a explosé et que l
air pour d'autres raisons aussi son coût
total du crédit actuelle tu voudrais
vraiment dire qu'elle est bien parce que
c'est facile d'avoir une finalement une
vision très caricatural de ce qui se
passe à l'échelle politique sur les
chefs sur le plan du bipolarisme entre
le ps et l'ump quoi lr aujourd'hui moi
je veux juste dire une chose
effectivement 39 ans macron il
représente peut-être une forme de
rajeunissement salutaire et donc il ya
un réel besoin effectivement gras de
rené matte revue oui à 49 ans il déjeune
effectivement même en politique mais là
l'expérience contrairement à d'autres
qui dit que pour citer emmanuel macron
qui dit que c'est même plus c'est même
plus tendance d'être élu puisse et c'est
finalement caduque et obsolète donc
c'est une rom est remise en question
totale de la démocratie qui pour moi me
dérange profondément et le finalement un
ravalement de façade que propose macron
n'est pas un réel renouvellement
opposés politiquement pour marino porte
pour marine le pen finalement cette
jumelle macron lepez c'est le scénario
idéal pas déjà emmanuel macron c'est
quand même l'hologramme de françois
hollande
il était de 2012 à 2014 son conseiller à
l'elysée il était ensuite pendant deux
années
son ministre de l'économie donc ces
parfaites hologram
il représente exactement ce que les
français ne veulent plus c'est le
candidat des banques c'est le candidat
ultra mondialistes donc emmanuel
emmanuel macron c'est véritablement cet
hologramme marine où on sur le terrain
le sang avec marine mais ça me faisait
rage qu'ils sont en tête
quand même parce qu on peut dire que les
gens de la droite dure et à de plus vers
vous alors déjà le clivage gauche droite
il existe plus moyennant et sur un
clivage qui est le clivage entre les
mondialistes que représente macron à mon
sillon et les patriotes que représente
marine le pen donc nous sur le terrain
on sent cette cette force montée on sent
cette adhésion au programme présidentiel
que porte marine le pen
donc il ya un verre il ya une véritable
adhésion à ce programme et donc oui moi
je pense que que marine le pen sera élu
et qu'elle battre à plate couture
emmanuel macron vous êtes d'accord avec
cette idée que les qui nagent que je
crois qu'il n'existe plus gallois alors
je suis pas d'accord dans la mesure où
il ya quand même des propositions dans
le programme de marine le pen qui sont
marqués très très à droite et comme dans
le pré l'émission jeu mélenchon se sont
marqués 13 à gauche là où je suis devant
vous vous dites
albert nous sommes durs alors gauche
hurle là on dit parce qu'on a un
programme de rassemblement pour le coup
qui n'a pas de marqueurs gauche ou
droite donc on peut vraiment se
revendiquer comme tel et c'est pas
seulement nous qui le disons puisque au
dos des élections le ministère de
l'intérieur nous a classé en liste
divers non pas divers gauche ni divers
droite donc le conseil le mystère
interne lui même reconnaît que nous
sommes au-dessus de ce clivage et moi
pour ce qui est des sondages je ne fais
absolument aucun cas des sondages il ne
teste pas tous les candidats et en plus
tout les des élections un chercheur à
quand les
toutes les dernières élections ont
montré que ces les sondages servait plus
à est une sorte de prophétie auto
réalisatrice et influencer l'opinion et
les électeurs dans les urnes et moi je
fais confiance aux français alors bon
sens ont à chaque fois démentie tous les
derniers sondages donc je me prête pas
attention aux sondages
vincent chauvet quelles priorités par
dessus tout les autres est la plus
importante dans un programme
présidentiel
en tout cas aux yeux des centres et je
pense que c'est vraiment la moralisation
de la vie politique
sans revenir vraiment la termine
finalement c'est un outil mais c'est là
où ça change c'est et c'est aussi sur le
changement des règles démocratiques
notamment l'introduction d'une
proportionnelle notamment l'allemand
dont on pourra avoir enfin au parlement
discuter avec l'extrême droite débattre
ou où les contredire on pourra avoir des
coalitions ou des ententes ou des
alliances entre des gens qui aujourd'hui
étaient séparés par des barrières
différentes la situation par exemple de
l'allemagne aujourd'hui qu'à une
situation économique bien meilleur même
si certains défauts que la france où le
secteur sort justement c'est ce qu'a dit
benoît hamon hier le taux de chômage est
à 7% le taux de chômage des jeunes est à
8% quand en france le taux de chômage
des jeunes entre 18 et 24 ans et de 25
de travail du giat l'entrée car ise
yahia d il ya des choses à améliorer
mais personne ne peut nier que la
situation économique de l'allemagne est
aujourd'hui bien meilleure que celle de
la france
et cette situation économique et le
produit et le produit d'un système
politique où des gens de centre-droit et
de centre gauche
ces familles qui ont aussi fait l'europe
qui ont fait la construction européenne
sont capables de s'entendre sur des
réformes concrètes sur des réformes de
compétitivité sur des réformes
budgétaires qui font qu'aujourd'hui
alors que l'allemagne et la france était
un niveau comparable et une dizaine
d'années l'allemagne est bien meilleur
et bien en avance donc la clé pour
changer le fonctionnement politique et
l'émergence du fn est la conséquence de
sa d'un système complètement délabré
complètement délabré entre deux parties
qui représente au final plus ria est
plus qu'une minorité des français c'est
de changer les règles
emmanuel macron qui vient d'ailleurs et
qui arrivent là soutenue par des forces
de droite et de gauche et le seul
capable de changer de manière
raisonnable la démocratie francs il ya
des propositions d'ampoulés aigles et
les tâches aux appareils si vous avez
fait allusion à l'europe c'est vrai que
c'est un peu le village de
ici on vote d'opposition vous êtes pour
la sortie de l'euro du coup on vous fait
à quoi ça sert
on a l'impression que c'est la recette
magique la sortie de l'euro pourquoi
alors des gens parle pas d'europe
je vous parlais de l'union européenne le
programme laissant dans les 144
engagement présidentielle de marine le
pen
tout est expliqué dans le programme de
marine sur sur l'union européenne est
simple nous voulons redonner notre
souveraineté au peuple
macron amont gauche droite ont
clairement abandonné notre souveraineté
le programme de marine sur un sur
l'union européenne
c'est donc de reprendre notre
souveraineté monétaire donc disposer de
notre propre monnaie
comme dans 95% des pays du monde donc on
passe aux français c'est également
c'est également donc retrouvé notre
souveraineté législatives car il faut
quand même rappeler à nos
téléspectateurs que l'union européenne
doit voter son budget elle doit ensuite
validée au niveau européen le budget que
propose l'état français pour qu'ils
puissent être transposée en droit
français pressé on entrait partie de
l'union européenne donc ensuite je
voudrais juste terminée parce que je
pense qu'il faut quand même expliqué on
est là pour pourrait mettre nos
propositions et défendre les engagements
de nos candidats et il faut également
donc retrouver notre notre souveraineté
budgétaire il faut pouvoir être maître
chez nous nous ne le sommes plus est
donc là et le programme de marine
retrouvé notre souveraineté pour pouvoir
mener notre politique pour les français
nisrine zaïbi qu'est ce qui est
différent si finalement le problème de
monsieur macron à celui de monsieur
hamon justement là je voulais rebondir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit par les deux
protagonistes aujourd'hui mais un
maquereau on propose quand même il n'est
pas dans le renouvellement comme on
croit il est dans la continuité pure et
simple de ce qui s'est fait jusqu'à
présent mois pour moi un modèle
économique libéral n'est pas un modèle
justement qui va à transformer en
profondeur les choses puisque c'est ce
qui s'est fait jusqu'à présent en europe
et c'est ce qui continue à se faire
malheureusement en terme sur le plan
économique ici en france
nous ce qu'on propose c'est de rompre
justement avec cette continuité qui est
proposée par
macron quand on parle des retraites on
peut parler des retraites on peuvent
parmi celles-ci on peut parler de plein
d'éléments justement de fond très précis
qui montre la différence entre benoît
hamon qui lui se soucie justement nos
personnes âgées parce que personne parle
de la détresse de la souffrance qu'ont
justement nos personnes âgées
il ya une démocratie grecque est
justement qui fait qu'il ya un des
personnes âgées énormément nombreuses
qui sont en souffrance qui sortent
justement en retraite et qui n'ont pas
vraiment les moyens de subvenir à leurs
besoins primaires se payer un loyer avec
une retraite à 400 600 euros c'est quoi
on n'est pas franchement on n'est pas
digne
on n'est pas digne pour la sixième
puissance économique de ne pas apporter
des réponses et des solutions concrètes
à ces personnes c'est le seul candidat
aujourd'hui qui s'adresse à cette
population en particulier sur les
questions dépendance c'est ça les
valeurs de gauche moi je mets au défi
macron quand il dit que certains qui
n'ont pas eu la chance finalement de
travail et nous pourrons pas avoir de
retraite
mais ce système ce système de route de
retraite allemand c'est le système de
retraite elle pointe qui dit que ceux
qui ne travaillent moins ne pourront pas
avoir une retraite juste de rentrer
après monsieur diallo selon le système
de retraite par points celui qui a été
défendue depuis longtemps par plusieurs
familles politiques et par plusieurs
syndicats dont la cfdt
c'est d'avoir un système qui aujourd'hui
est complètement illisible on ne sait
pas c'est impossible de calculer sa
retraite notamment si on a fait
plusieurs carrières et si on la changer
de branche et c est de dire on va comme
les salariés du privé on reconnaît bien
caj agirc-arrco les retraites
complémentaires
on va cotiser et chaque euro cotisé quel
que soit le salarié donnera droit aux
mêmes droits à la retraite ensuite avec
un point qui est mis à jour en fonction
des équilibres pour qu'on ait un système
pérenne équilibré et qui donnent
confiance parce qu'aujourd'hui
moi personnellement et je défie tout mon
tour de la table de notre de notre âge
des trentenaires de dire qu'est ce qu'on
a confiance dans notre système de
retraite moi quand je regarde comment on
cotise et comment on peut être on aura
une retraite et en disant que ça va
peut-être changer avec des réformes qui
n'ont été que des réformes est pour
l'instant plus personne n'a confiance
d'un système de retraite offert un
système de retraite par points c'est
mettre de la clarté de la justesse de l'
équilibre et redonner la confiance dans
le système tout en portant beaucoup
madame le pen l'interné on est sur le
programme et c'est ce qui est
intéressant parce que fondamentalement
une vision on voit des gens qui nous
disent qu'ils vont faire différemment et
on a des personnes qui sont dans la
continuité comme monsieur macron la
vraie réalité c'est que dans le cadre
des traités européens
vous ne ferez rien tous autant que vous
êtes autour de la table à les traiter
siens mais attendez je voulais partir
mais j'ai pas le souvenir de ce galop
ainsi presque inférences donc je suis
notamment pu donc moi j'ai avec moi le
programme qui appliquera tous les
candidats si jamais ils sont élus sauf
françois sinon c'est celui de la
commission européenne et les grandes
orientations politiques économiques
c'est l'article 121 du traité ce
fonction lui au pmc la commission qui
décide tout les grandes réformes
économiques et sociales pour tous les
pays
donc que ce soit monsieur macron madame
le pen ou monsieur hamon c'est ce qui
sera appliqué
il ya entre autres la réduction totale y
compris les actions de la sécurité
sociale attendait jeudi la réduction des
coûts du travail et la modération du
smic réforme lru travail réformer
l'assurance chômage comme le dit
monsieur macron on a bien compris comme
il était toujours la sortie de l'école
ce qui est bien ce qui est fondamental
et je vais je finirai là dessus si vous
pensez que tous les candidats proposent
finalement de réformer les traités or il
faut que les français comprennent que
c'est impossible puisqu'il faut
l'unanimité des 28 états membres
il faut l'utiliser d'allemand dans 8
s'est posé sur les rails et donc à ce
moment là il ya que françois cieux qui
proposent de sortir propose de réformer
les traités mentent aux français on a
compris qu il y en aura sur les
retraites insu sur les retraites
déjà le débat est plus large que ça sur
les retraites il faut donc ce débat ce
débat aux classes moyennes
ce sont eux les véritables les
véritables s'oublier se parle également
de la précarité dans laquelle se
trouvent les classes moyennes les petits
retraités du fait de cette
mondialisation sauvage du fait de cette
du fait de cette europe et pour pouvoir
permettre voir des retraites correctes
après que les personnes ayant travaillé
toute leur vie c'est simple il faut
instaurer du patriotisme économique pour
que les pour que pour que le travail
puisse revenir en france que le travail
soit fournie aux entreprises françaises
en priorité si on recrée pas ce
patriotisme économique
si on retrouve pas notre souveraineté
rien ne changera emmanuel macron qu'est
ce qu'ils proposent
il propose d'augmenter la csg de 25 il
conservait exactement le même projet que
la gauche au pouvoir passe
donc je le rappelle encore une fois
c'est le propre hologrammes de hollande
il était son conseiller donc il l'a
guidé dans ses démarches
j'en veux donc ensuite non il faut il
faut véritablement remettre à plat ce
système et permettre de garantir des
retraites décentes aux français et sa
marine
allez je vous donne 10 secondes à chacun
quelles premières mesures voudriez voir
que votre candidat s'il est élu
président prenne dès qu'il arrive à
l'elysée monsieur gallois l'a senti
d'union nous c'est très clair nous
activerons l'article 50 comme le fonds
de sécurité nick qui propose à chaque
état membre de retrouver sa souveraineté
et sa démocratie et donc de donner aux
français un vrai joueur sorti de l'union
européenne de l'euro et de l'otan avec
françois c'est l'union de merci mais ça
peut faire mal gré sur un point que je
trouve extrêmement important c'est le
numérique
emmanuel macron c'est aussi le candidat
qui a compris la transformation
numérique de la société et il propose un
fonds d'investissement européen parce
que quoi qu'on en dise l'économie se
fait à l'échelle du continent qui
permettra d'amorcer les start up et
d'amener le continent vers l'innovation
si il y en a trop rapidement marine le
pen remettra en cinq ans la france en
ordre pour ce faire elle permettra de
retrouver notre souveraineté
nos quatre souveraineté et enfin elle
permettra de redonner la liberté au
peuple
ah ça c'est en cinq ans est la première
mesure juste déçu de ne pas pouvoir
parler de l'europe mais bon la première
mesure c'est la 6ème république avec la
moralisation justement et d'éthique
remis à plat pour pouvoir redonner
confiance en fin une fois pour toutes
aux représentants justement du peuple
merci beaucoup je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez voir ou revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet sur notre page
facebook la semaine prochaine nous nous
intéresserons aux jeunes militants en
politique à leur regard sur la
présidentielle mais tout de suite
place à l'information régionale avec
emmanuel pinsonneault et dimanche en
politique revient juste après l'invité
aujourd'hui de francis letellier jean
luc mélenchon très longuement chaque
liste
non